[Música]
usted preguntará por qué dormimos
o cuando dormimos o cuando dormimos o
como dormimos lo bueno es que la ciencia
tiene respuestas a todas estas preguntas
y sorprendentemente simple la respuesta
de la ciencia porque como cuando cuanto
dormimos es muy fácil ni idea aumentito
los científicos no saben algo tan obvio
como lo que nos pasa todas las noches o
nos debiera pasar todas las noches no no
no sabemos eso es maravilloso
en cierta forma nos convierte a todos
nosotros en científicos todos podemos
hacer experimentos con nuestro sueño de
que la persona que tenemos al lado el de
nuestros amigos desde nuestra familia y
eso también es hacer ciencia bueno no
está ni idea algunas cosas sabemos saber
por ejemplo por qué dormimos bueno eso
parece bastante obvia uno duerme porque
tiene sueño o está cansado es tan obvio
ahora piensen un cachito cuando están de
vacaciones así que no están cansados no
hacen nada
duerme mucho menos no y cuando hace
mucho ejercicio tiene una tarea muy
demandante desde lo físico duerme mucho
más no con lo cual no es solamente está
alcanzado algo de eso hay
probar más cosas al por qué dormimos
algo sabemos que dormir es importante
hace muchos años se hacían experimentos
en los cuales se de privaba a animales
del sueño no se los dejaba dormir y
saben lo que les pasaba se morían y se
morían en dos semanas como si no
comieran dormir es vital es tan
importante como comer y qué más pasa en
el sueño un montón de cosas
crecemos el cuerpo se repara se
recuperan energías montón de cosas que
si no durmiéramos no ocurrirían se
consolidan las memorias lo peor que
pueden hacer si tiene un examen o algo
importante es no dormir estudiando
porque seguro les va a ir mal así que de
él porque sabemos algo pero no del todo
qué pasa con él cuando cuando dormimos
nosotros evolucionamos como bichos
diurnos
tenemos que estar activos de día y
dormir de noche y guardándose en la web
alejado de los peligros alejados de eso
que está pasando allá afuera y por qué
es eso porque tenemos un pedacito de
cerebro que mide el tiempo y le dice al
cuerpo qué hora es el reloj biológico en
cierta forma somos relojes con patas
todo lo que hacemos ocurre en el tiempo
no solamente en el espacio dormir
también ocurre en el tiempo ocurre o
debiera ocurrir de noche pero cada vez
está pasando menos eso estamos robándole
horas a la noche para ganar en la
vigilia desde la invención de la luz
eléctrica ese gran ladrón de sueño cada
vez nos vamos más y más tarde nuestro
cuerpo no está preparado para eso de
hecho es cierto que hay gente con más
necesidades o menos de dormir dormís más
temprano o más tarde hay gente es más
matutina en las cargas los llamamos
alondras algunos de ustedes la están
pasando muy bien en este horario otros
son los búhos más vespertinos que
todavía están bastante somnoliento desde
que se trata dónde estoy
de hecho hasta hay personas muy pero muy
matutinas los alondras extremos y
personas muy pero muy o espartinas los
jugos extremos pueden llegar a pasar
cada tanto que una alondra extremo
conozca a un búho extremo y se casen
en este caso los hijos son un milagro
pero hay que escuchar ese reloj que nos
dice cuándo hacer las cosas cuando estar
despiertos cuando dormir a veces entra
en conflicto con la realidad con la
sociedad con el horario del trabajo del
colegio por ejemplo los adolescentes son
típicos jugos y hacen todo mucho más
tarde uno piensa que es cultural que los
llevan a cualquier hora chatean hasta
cualquier varón sus amigos salen muy
tarde hay muchos de cultural pero esa
cultura se monta sobre la necesidad
biológica de que el reloj les dice hace
todo más tarde cuál es el problema al
día siguiente el colegio a qué hora
empieza a las siete y pico de la mañana
lo cual es absurdo los pibes están
dormidos literalmente dormidos en las
primeras horas bueno tenemos que
trabajar sobre esto escuchar al reloj y
también que la sociedad de escuchar el
reloj y el cuánto cuánto dormimos cuánto
tenemos que dormir si yo lo llevo a
cualquiera de ustedes oa cualquier
persona al laboratorio de sueño y les
digo duerman lo que tengan ganas el
promedio de la gente adulta es de ocho
horas veinte minutos otro horas y media
dormimos 8 horas y media
dormí bastante menos se calcula estamos
durmiendo una hora menos que hace 50
años y unas dos horas menos que hace 100
años eso es mucho realmente es muchos de
esas horas ya nos estamos robando unas
dos horas de sueño es más podríamos
hacer una proyección si dormimos dos
horas menos que hace cien años y cinco y
una hora menos que hace 50 años si
hacemos la recta y las seguimos más o
menos para el año dos mil 758 no
dormimos más
eso no puede pasar por el sueño es una
necesidad pero la necesidad también es
de horas de sueño y eso es para los
adultos
los adolescentes debieran dormir nueve
horas o más los chicos entre 9 y 10
horas y tampoco las están durmiendo por
muchos motivos el principal es social la
sociedad está comprimiendo las horas de
sueño nos trae problemas eso las
pantallas también nos perjudican porque
la luz que sale de las pantallas y nadie
duerme solo últimamente todos venimos
con una pantalla en la cama por las
dudas es una luz que le dice al reloj
que es de día por lo tanto le dice
despertadas te está todo bien seguí de
largo claro al día siguiente que
despertarse dormimos menos dormimos mal
ponemos poco y cuál es el problema uno
se preguntara producto y fenómenos y en
todo caso recupero el fin de semana cuál
es el problema de no dormir bien un
montón de problemas uno de los problemas
es que vamos a estar somnolientos
claramente vamos a estar con mucho sueño
durante el día cuando no podría
descansar no es grave está bien negro
una siesta vamos a estar de mal humor el
no dormir nos cambia el estado de ánimo
y eso es lo menos grave el estar
somnoliento
de mal humor no es tan grave como
enfermarnos no dormir es sinónimo de
enfermedad
en principio nos vamos a enfermar de más
infecciones el sistema inmune necesita
dormir para protegernos de lo que está
allá afuera pero también nos vamos a
enfermar de trastornos metabólicos nos
enferma de diabetes cuando esto es
crónico cuando la de privación de sueño
es crónica aparecen las enfermedades por
lo tanto enormes no es solamente un
problema individual empieza a ser un
problema de salud pública el sueño y
todos tenemos que ser conscientes de
esto seguro que ustedes oyeron hablar de
un concepto que es el desierto sin el
teclado es lo que ocurre cuando uno
vuela si atraviesa un sus horarios de
gas a destino para el mundo es una hora
para voces o te estás medio zombie
durante unos días hasta que te acomodas
con ese nuevo horario bueno si viajas
por turismo no es nada grave pero si
viajas por trabajo la cosa puede ser
complicada el asunto es que uno puede
tener jetlag sin moverse de su casa
cuando el horario de la sociedad es
distinto del horario que tenés acá
adentro tenéis lo que se llama jetlag
social y todos tenemos es la social
todos nos despertamos con una alarma por
lo tanto no los estamos despertando en
el momento de nuestro reloj biológico lo
dice
es más podría ocurrir un sercla social
bastante más grave imagínense que vuelan
de acá a áfrica y se quedan una semana
de áfrica vuelan hacia y se queda una
semana y de acá son amos porque me quedo
en el medio del pacífico vuelo en la de
isla de pascua y se quedan una semana y
vuelven bastante chiflado hacer eso no
eso es lo que hacen los trabajadores que
están en turnos de trabajo rotativos una
semana trabajan de día otra de tarde
otra de noche como si estuvieran volando
alrededor del mundo todo el tiempo y
obviamente se enferman de lo mismo y
dijimos antes de trastornos metabólicos
trastornos cardiovasculares y además la
ub meses la organización mundial de la
salud puso al trabajo en turnos
rotativos un factor de riesgo para el
cáncer nada menos así que es dormir mal
dormir a deshoras no es cualquier cosa
hay que prestar atención nosotros
investigamos esto en el laboratorio
investigamos cuando dormimos cuanto
dormimos porque necesitamos datos
necesitamos evidencia para después
volcar lo a la sociedad también
estudiamos qué pasaba en esos chicos que
tienen que levantarse tan temprano para
ir al colegio
y nuestra secreta esperanza es de
retrasar un cachito el horario de inicio
de las clases cosa que se imaginan cada
vez que decimos esto en la escuela somos
héroes también investigamos qué pasa con
estos trabajadores de turnos rotativos
para ver cómo mejorar su calidad de vida
y por qué hacemos todo esto mi sitio
porque lo que hacemos en el laboratorio
y en algún momento ojalá llegue a esa
sociedad además porque es lo que soñamos
todos soñamos con un reloj que ande bien
que esté adaptado al mundo que no nos
enferme y como todo el mundo queremos
cumplir con nuestros sueños quien no
quiere cumplir con sus sueños pero para
cumplir con sus sueños hay que empezar
por algo bastante obvio no soñar los y
para soñar que hay que hacer dormir
muchas gracias
[Música]